هل يمكن حل قضيه قضيه من هذه القضايا
برايك يعني قضيه الصومال لوحدها قضيه
افغانستان لوحدها قضيته اوكرانيا لوحدها
ام ان الحل يجب ان يكون عالميا وهل يمكن
ان يكون الحل
بالمساعدات الانسانيه وتقديم مثل هذه
اللجان الانقاذ ام ان الحل يجب ان يكون
سياسيا بالدرجه الاولى
عده اشكال واعراض لابد من البحث عن
الاسباب الرئيسيه في اي تحليل يظهر بان
هناك اتجاهات دوليه
على اثنين منها اولا همم
حالتي النظام السياسي المتشردم الذي وصل
الى حاله الجمود الذي كان قد تسبب
بحالات النصفيه منظمات الدوله
سببين الرئيسيين ومعالجه الاعراض فان
اللجنه الدوليه هي من المنظمات المدنيه
الاساسيه التي تعتمد على الاناث المحليين
الذين يعملون لدينا والدعم العلمي
والحقيقه او الماساه
بين الاحتياجات العالميه التي وصفتها
وكيفيه سد هذه الفجوه
المتسبب زياره في الشرق الاوسط الضوء على
هذه الفجوه على زوجتها